scientists predicted what would happen  but it was too late  [Music]  this is same Walden if anyone can hear  this broadcast I'm still on earth this  is dr. Walden transmitting on frequency  1943 the world we once called home  appears of turn against us the  fundamental principle of nature is  survival it is in our soul to seek life  no matter what I heard the radio  transmission where is everyone else  there is no one else did the same  everywhere  yes the same everywhere  boza like before I was gonna be a  teacher but we weren't ready for that  you're going to the final Exodus  launched this work for my dad leaving  was just a last resort  I saw dozens of people starve to death  because of hope how home made the same  mistake twice when do we leave  the final settled offer thesis at 48  hours  a long way to travel we mess up and we  die we need to stay the night in the  toxic zone it's not possible it's  possible but farther than I've ever gone  let's do this  trust me  [Music]  you